Making a direct sequel to a moving decades
later is becoming more common recently.
It presents a unique challenge for directors
and cinematographer as they have to find the
balance between creating something that feels
connected to the original film while still
creating something that feel unique and new.
Here is Denis Villeneuve, the director of
Blade Runner 2049 describing his relationship
to the original Blade Runner film…
Denis and Director of Photography Roger Deakins develop a unique
visual style, updating the world and the production
design for a story that takes place long after
the original events.
Roger Deakins often abandons the hard high
contrast lighting of the original for more
soft and diffused lighting.
Production design has been updated to reflect
the changes in the world.
But there are still visual connections, the
ones that I’ve highlighted here that ground
2049 in a familiar space.
Re-occurring places feel similar, and visual
motifs are used to link past and present characters
and themes.
Threading the needle of being original while
remaining true to the source material is difficult.
I think where 2049 succeeds is by making these
references subtly enough that it doesn’t
feel formulaic or forced.
Most of the visual references are made during
segments of the film that are establishing
or transitioning shots.
2049 doesn’t lean on those references to
be the weight of the film, instead it uses
them to allude to
a familiar place and world, while building
towards
a story that is fresh.